Plus sérieusement, on dit tous qu'on déteste ces conneries.
La question est de savoir si on est prêt à se sacrifier pour changer ça.
Je ne veux pas dire laisser tomber Internet.
Je veux dire changer la façon dont nous cliquons,
parce que cliquer est un acte public.
Ce n'est plus vrai qu'une petite élite puissante
contrôle tous les médias et que les autres
ne sont que des récepteurs passifs.
De plus en plus, nous sommes tous les médias.
Avant, je me disais : « Ok, je me mets sur mon trente-et-un ,
je mets des tonnes de maquillage,
je passe à la télé, et je parle des infos.
Ça, c'est un acte public de création de médias.
Et puis je rentre chez moi, je surfe sur le net, je lis Twitter,
et c'est un acte privé de consommation de médias.
Évidemment que ça l'est, je suis en pyjama. »
Faux.
Tout ce que nous bloguons, twittons,
et tout ce sur quoi que nous cliquons
est un acte public de création de médias.
Nous sommes les nouveaux éditeurs.
Nous décidons de ce qui mérite notre attention
en nous basant sur ce à quoi nous prêtons attention.
Voilà comment fonctionnent les médias aujourd'hui.
Ce sont tous ces algorithmes cachés qui décident
de ce que nous voyons davantage
en fonction de ce sur quoi nous cliquons,
et en retour, c'est ce qui définit toute notre culture.
Plus de 3 Américains sur 5 pensent que
nous faisons face à un problème d'incivilité majeur dans notre pays,
mais j'imagine qu'au moins trois Américains sur cinq
cliquent sur les mêmes idioties insultantes
qui lancent des rumeurs nourrissant
les pulsions les plus méchantes dans notre société.
Dans un paysage médiatique toujours plus bruyant,
l'objectif est de faire plus de bruit pour être entendu,
et cette tyrannie du bruyant
encourage la tyrannie de la méchanceté.
Il ne doit pas forcément en être ainsi.
Pas forcément.
Nous pouvons changer la donne.
Il y a des choses que nous pouvons tous faire.
D'abord, ne restez pas à l'écart quand vous voyez quelqu'un être blessé.
Si quelqu'un est maltraité en ligne, faites quelque chose.
Soyez un héros. C'est votre chance.
Parlez franchement. Parlez fort. Soyez une bonne personne.
Noyez le négatif par le positif.
Ensuite, nous devons arrêter de cliquer
sur les liens les plus minables.
Si vous ne voulez pas voir du Kardashian
programmé en continu 24h/24 et 7j/7,
vous devez arrêter de cliquer sur les articles
à propos du morceau de sein de Kim Kardashian qui dépasse sur le côté.
Je sais que vous le faites. (Applaudissements)
Vous aussi apparemment.
Si vous n'aimez pas que les politiciens se traitent de tous les noms,
arrêtez de cliquer sur les articles à propos de ce qu'un gars d'un parti
a dit d'un gars de l'autre parti.
Cliquer sur ce genre d'articles ne fait qu'embraser le tout.
Ça ne fait que tout empirer, le feu se répand.
Toute notre culture brûle.
Si ce qui reçoit le plus de clics gagne,
alors nous devons commencer à créer
le monde que nous voulons avec nos clics,
parce que cliquer est un acte public.
Alors cliquez de façon responsable.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)